you don't have to love racing to love
Gran Turismo because what you're really
watching is this feel-good sports movie
it's the incredible true story of a
gamer who became a professional race car
driver and changed the most elite sport
in the world welcome to Team Nissan John
is this kid who has no understanding of
the racing World apart from a video game
what do you thought about going back to
all I ever wanted to do is be a racer
not again about the race car so you're
the one that told us to always do
something we love it's about trying to
achieve new dreams look around that's
not our world son
you know about racing cars cars Jan gets
this opportunity who is this
it's a contest the best Gran Turismo
players in the wall get a chance to
compete in professional racing be
careful everybody's really counting yard
out saying he can't win I can't see
anything
oh
I'm not sure if I can do this most
people can't I got a feeling you're not
most people
together I'm not gonna quit
[Music]
they'd start to believe they can do the
impossible come on get in the fight
Gran Turismo based on a Dory